no hop at unist well degeneration Ishak
generous european a suppo priest well
today we face our very own defining
moment what started with a virus so
small your eyes couldn't see it has
become an economic crisis so big that
you simply cannot miss it
our unique model built over 70 years is
being challenged like never before in
our lifetime on our unions history this
is why the Commission is today proposing
a new recovery instrument called
next-generation EU worth 750 billion
euro it will sit on top of a revamped
long-term EU budget of 1.1 trillion
next generation EU together with a core
MFF sums up to one point eight five
trillion euro in today's proposal it
goes alongside the three safety nets of
540 billion euro already agreed by
parliament and council and in sum this
would bring our recovery effort to a
total of two point four trillion euro
next generation you will invest in
repairing our social fabric protect our
single market help rebalancing balance
sheets across Europe and while we are
doing this we need to press fast forward
towards the green a digital and
resilient future because this is the
future of Europe's next generation in
total the Commission will raise seven
750 billion euro for next generation EU
of that total 500 billion will be
distributed in brands and 250 billion in
loans
passed on to member states decrease
material gets onion Mozgov eightish
about urban saga voltage is DeShazer for
Europa old UN's lava and rotten Indies
as it was Rhonda's really good so tune
we can yet
Deacon's Lardon League final Union de
clima Nautilus the digitalis the hobos
doesn't is Oceanus better of Castel as
he'd sue for via lint thus dennis nino
gaggi own surely long labor opa vivo up
long live Europe
[Applause]